eu sempre quis mudar quis contribuir com
a mudança na forma de olhar das pessoas
para elas mesmas e para o mundo
eu sempre gostei de desenhar um trabalho
que eu faço hoje e me permite entrar em
contato com muitas pessoas e
consequentemente conhecer a história de
muitas pessoas
uma delas é do doutor márcio doutor
márcio eu conheci no interior de goiás
ele é especialista em hidrogeologia até
então nem tinha ouvido falar disso
ele pesquisa como que a água interage
com o solo
ele foi contratado por uma empresa de
mineração que trabalha no interior de
goiás para explicar à população daquela
região porque a água de lá estava
acabando em torno da menina não eu não
tomasse como um super socialista que ele
era e levou uma série de informações
para ele eram muito claras e levou
gráficos falando do índice pluviométrico
ele levou imagens de satélite da área
você não já que chovia mas já tinha -
ele mostrou análises químicas do solo
porque que um solo é recebia mais água e
outro não
e pra estava claro claríssimo que ele
falava com uma segurança muito grande
mas a platéia muito perto de onde eu
estava sentado tinha o seu joão e sua
família seu joão é um agricultor que tem
uma fazenda perto da mina
ele mora com a esposa e com filho dele
lá e o seu joão o olhava pro doutor
marcos com aquela cara de quem já estava
acostumado a receber na região uma série
de pessoas que eram especialistas mas
que não comunicavam nada e aí eu percebi
que naquele dia o havia um buraco ali
que não é só buraco da mina que estava
sendo falado pelo doutor márcio havia um
buraco da falta de falta de entendimento
a falta de entendimento que aconteceu
dos dois lados
do lado do seu jogo da sua fala da
família dele que não entendia nada do
que eu mas tá falando do lado do doutor
márcio que não entende a realidade do
seu joão a ponto de traduzir pra ele
aquele que pra ele tava claro e eu
percebi que eu tenho percebido
nos últimos 12 anos que eu trabalho com
esse tipo de linguagem que a esse buraco
da falta de entendimento ele existem
vários meios
eu percebo isso no médico doutor em
entomologia quem sabe que entomologia né
então hoje quem estuda os insetos doutor
em entomologia que é especialista na
antena do mosquito da dengue e ele
precisa passar para a população como que
a população se prevenir da dengue
eu vejo isso às vezes um gestor precisa
dar um feedback na sua equipe
eu vejo isso no professor que precisa
passar o conteúdo complexo o aluno e
isso sempre me incomoda esse buraco que
existe é um desnível de informação entre
as duas partes e por por muito tempo eu
tento achar formas de reduzir o buraco
da falta de entendimento entre as
pessoas
e aí eu já fiz bastante coisa eu já
criei jogo para ensinar a ciência para
adolescentes já fiz um desenho animado
para explicar para as crianças como é
que elas porque elas não podem entrar na
lagoa nas pegas xistose naves
apresentação de powerpoint para as
empresas
as pessoas falaram nas empresas sobre as
metas já fiz cartilha para a criança mas
nenhuma dessas é tecnologias me deixaram
satisfeito porque muitas vezes elas
continham o texto demais e não se
aproximavam da linguagem de quem é
receber aquilo
isso mudou e eu vou mostrar pra vocês
como isso mudou
mas vou dar uns passos atrás porque nem
sempre desenhei a ideia das pessoas
eu já fui psicólogo porque é aquilo que
eu falei no começo eu não acreditava que
aquilo que eu gostava de fazer realmente
era desenhar poderia mudar a vida das
pessoas então eu procurei uma profissão
que se encaixava um pouco mais no meu
perfil que ela escutar bem as pessoas só
levou o psicólogo mas como quando a
gente tem alguma coisa que está dentro
da gente que é mais forte do que a gente
faça eu sempre fui muito tempo sendo um
psicólogo muito tempo dois anos
eu ficava pensando poxa queria desenhar
a vida tivesse desenhando e é o seu
balde e mesmo trabalhar num empresa
educação a distância foi lucas tem uma
vaga para ilustrador lá vão lá fazer meu
irmão como incentivar pra caramba
só que eu nunca fui um desenhista eu
gostava de desenhar e tem uma diferença
nisso né
se gostar de fazer uma coisa nessa gosta
de cozinhar seu chefe então fui lá fazer
eu lembro até hoje cheguei na empresa
totalizam e tal aí era uma empresa
grande e 200 pessoas ea baía dos
ilustradores assim desde lustrador e
olhando para a tela de cada um assim é
cada sendo um carro super cabuloso ou
desenhando um desenho e perspectiva nem
sabia como fazer perspectiva perspectiva
que eu tenho trabalhando na orientação
profissional na perspectiva de vida e aí
eu fiz o teste e ilustrador ele fala
desde um personagem desenho né só saber
desenhar eu não passei
mas sorte que lá tinha uma vaga para
design design como está escrito aí
porque na verdade eu entrei como
diagramador e pelo tempo que eu
trabalhei lá eu acreditei
me convenci de que eu não sabia desenhar
o que eu vi eu me comparar com as
pessoas vão falar pô eu acho que estou
dizendo que não vou fazer bonecos
político e ele também falava em nome do
café e só não sei design sempre do lado
pois é mas o legal é que alguma coisa me
diferencial deles dos ilustradores que
tinham lá entrei em contato com uma área
que chama design de informações que ela
busca o meio de elementos de design
conseguir transmitir uma informação
adequada a um público muito dos
desenhistas que eram super profissionais
tentavam mas não conseguiam fazer isso
ele sabia fazer um excelente desenho mas
não conseguiram transmitir uma ideia
para o público e aí depois de um bom
tempo eu montei minha empresa de 78 e eu
descobri uma coisa que me fez desenhar
um novo caminho e voltar a acreditar que
eu sabia desenhar que é o pensamento
visual como funciona o pensamento visual
aplicado que é o que eu faço hoje e
vamos lugares colocam um painel de papel
bem grande e à medida que as pessoas vão
falando em uma reunião uma palestra uma
aula eu desenho aquilo que elas estão
falando de um jeito que elas possam
entender de 1
muito mais fácil mas o mais legal disso
tudo é que os traços eles precisam ser
simples a gente não tem tempo para
trabalhar é um tráfico ele tem que ser
mais simples possível
uma segunda coisa que é interessante
disso é que no pensamento visual foco é
muito mais na idéia do que na arte
porque na arte muitas vezes os meninos
que trabalha com ilustração o próprio
artista é focado na sua própria técnica
ele focado no seu mundo interior como é
que ela quer passar para o outro
nesse caso não nesse caso o nosso foco é
no outro é no que o outro fala então
quando você consegue focar no que o
outro fala e não resultado em si não
importa se você desenhar um círculo
torto uma casa que não tá reta um boneco
distorcido
a pessoa vê aquilo era identificar então
é isso que quero dizer
você cumpriu seu papel mas uma coisa que
é muito interessante disso é quando você
desenha ideia das pessoas
você consegue nivela o entendimento das
pessoas
foi o que aconteceu lá no doutor marcos
no seu já 16 lembra né
o nível estava em baixo porque não tinha
uma conexão
eu tinha ido lá para poder desenhar o
que o doutor marcos falava isso é um
resumo do que foi feito tão pequenininho
porque na verdade não precisam saber
porque acabou a água lá na na mina ele
precisava mas o que aconteceu foi o
seguinte na hora que o doutor márcio
terminou a palestra dele lá fala
eles entregaram um microfone para as
pessoas fazerem perguntas e aí eu já
levantou e não foi imediatamente fazer
perguntas e ficou do lado do painel um
tempo observando o painel olhando
olhando ele pegou o microfone e falou
doutor pelo que eu estou vendo aqui não
pelo que ele tinha dito pelo que eu
estou vendo aqui a água está acabando
porque a gente usa mais água tanto boi
porque a gente usa mais água fazendo tal
coisa e 60
eu não estava a serviço de nenhuma das
partes eu estava a serviço de uma
comunicação que permitiu que houvesse
uma conexão entre as três partes uma
conexão quando você desenha ideia das
pessoas que é dada primeiro você aumenta
o nível do doutor márcio porque eles ver
aquela coisa que ele falou falou e às
vezes nem tinha percebido que eu falei
isso e ele se vê reconhecido ali é algo
que é também interessante para quem ouve
porque ela recebe uma informação que
aumenta o nível de entendimento dela
conversa e isso de certa forma em poder
a ela para poder questionar o que ela
não questionaria porque o nível de
informação estava diferente e ao mesmo
tempo isso também me deixa diferente
porque eu começo a ver o todo e começa a
perceber a realidade que antes não
percebia isso a empatia
às vezes a gente fica pensando como é
que eu me coloco no lugar do outro
o interessante disso é que por um
momento um meia ou duas horas
eu não me coloco no lugar do outro eu
sou o outro naquele momento eu era o
doutor marcos mais simplificado né e
mais novo é interessante isso assim
outro dia estava numa empresa
extrativistas extrai mineiro
ele estava é fazer uma reunião anual
para falar porque ele estava tendo
prejuízo e que eles corriam risco de
falir
eu como lucas olhares numa notícia de
jornal e achava ótimo falar que é legal
é uma empresa - traindo da natureza mas
ele estava desenhado no final da empresa
estava triste cara tava assim por nossa
nós vão entrar em férias coletivas e se
não funcionar nós vai ser demitido e é
isso sim naquele momento você não tem
tempo pra fazer seus julgamentos você
está ali para traduzir o que o outro
está falando isso empatia
o que é legal nesse caso é que quanto
mais simples o seu desenho mais empatia
ou seja era porque a gente começa a se
conectar com algo que é humano porque
nós somos todos os imperfeitos se eu
paro para desenhar um trabalho bem
elaborado
a pessoa não consegue criar uma conexão
porque ela vem aquela é um artista
quando eu faço um boneco vestido bem
curtinho pessoal veio falou pô eu
poderia fazer isso que ele está fazendo
ali
eu me vejo ali isso que a beleza então
legal disse o seguinte não precisa se
preocupar em desenhar
certamente esteticamente é belo e tal
o que importa é que nós temos essa
necessidade de sermos escutados e esse
tipo de atividade permite isso
caso você não tenha percebido sul de
minas
é bom deixar claro que as pessoas vão
pensar que eu sou gaúcho é o sotaque eo
mineiro ele tem essa identidade é
voltada para o território para a cultura
ea gastronomia muito forte né
qualquer um sabe o que é que é bond com
meninas de queijo é então e lá em minas
a gente tem uma feira que ela é uma
feira gastronômica de produtores
mineiros que é aberta ao público e
muitas vezes eu vou lá coloca esse meu
painel a convite do pessoal e coloca uma
frase que é uma frase para iniciar o a
interação das pessoas que é o que te
aproxima de minas gerais e se aproxima
de aproximar emocionalmente mesmo aí as
pessoas falam aquilo que a gente imagina
que é próximo de minas gerais imagino
que vocês vão pensar no pão de queijo
quem já foi menos na serra nas serras né
é no queijo minas é por acaso é uma
queijo minas
enfim é interessante toda vez que eu vou
nas feiras acontece isso falam essas
coisas né
é muito comum trem é difícil você não
sabe nem tá falando trem o que é mas
acontece um negócio acontecer um negócio
muito interessante assim é uma das
pessoas ela chegou e falou assim para
mim lucas desenha uma caixa registradora
ano
hoje eu não sei o quê caixa registradora
e tal e aí ela eu fui perguntar melhor
pra ela começou a falar olha quando era
criança morava lá com o meu pai lá no
interior de minas ele tinha um comércio
e uma caixa registradora que eu gostava
de brincar aquelas caixas vezes antes um
botão grande que apertava abrirá eu fui
desenhar caixa registradora ficou feliz
saiu mas o mais interessante disso é que
o desenho a caixa registradora que toda
hora ela voltava lá com alguém conhecido
ou não ela fala olha a caixa que eu
tinha quando era criança está desenhado
ali eu falei desenho e não dizer uma
caixa registradora
o desenho uma representação de uma caixa
registradora que para aquela mulher
falava assim o que você diz é importante
ela podia falar qualquer coisa
ponto de queijo mas o interessante disso
é que só se você olha pra pessoa e fala
o que você disse
é importante eu tô satisfazendo uma
necessidade sul de ser ouvida e disse se
sentir importante então quando eu falo
pro outro que você diz é importante eu
estou falando do outro você é importante
então muito mais do que saber desenhar é
você conseguir representar e ouvir o
outro piso a empatia e esse trabalho é
muito parecido com o processo de
comunicação focada na empatia e eu vou
falar pra vocês aqui as quatro etapas
básicas desse processo
e vocês vão ver que tem muito a ver
a primeira parte pra você ter uma idéia
das pessoas você tem uma escuta atenta
na maior parte das vezes as nossas
comunicações elas são feitas unilaterais
na pessoa fala já pensa no que vai
responder a ela sim ou não né pessoal
começou a falar já mesmo que não
responda literalmente já está concluindo
a idéia nesse caso de trabalho que a
gente faz a gente é uma ferramenta de
escuta e tem que ter presença nessa hora
não importa se você acha que a empresa
do cara vai falir ou não você tem que
registrar que ele falou não importa se
você já sabe a resposta do que ele está
buscando você tem que falar o que eles
têm que registrar o que ele falou
a segunda parte só é propiciado por
causa da primeira depois de uma escuta
atenta você busca essência você foca
naquilo que é importante eo processo de
comunicação empática esse né
é você escutar o outro entender o que é
importante depois você começa a criar
conexões começa a entender as relações
do que o outro fala e isso gera novos
sentidos para você e para o outro e
finalmente você apresenta as idéias
então veja só a 75% do da etapa sendo um
desenho
você escuta entende compreende conecta e
só no final você mostra para outras
ganhando ou não você fala para o outro
olha isso aqui você fala é importante
por isso por isso por aquilo e às vezes
vou falar o nome realmente faz sentido e
é nessa hora é interessante também
pensando na empatia por que você vai
usar de rede de referência de recursos
que tem
ver com o mundo do outro tem a ver com a
realidade do outro ajudou a desenhar uma
coisa que a pessoa não vai entender
e aí o resultado nesta bonita está feio
isso é algo que a gente deixa para as
análises técnicas o resultado dessa
mensagem foi passada ou não eu acredito
realmente que o desenho tem essa
esse potencial de conexão entre as
pessoas e quando em sines para as
pessoas
eu vejo que elas aprendem com muita
rapidez porque semelhante ao nosso ser a
gente desenha desde que era homens e
mulheres das cavernas
ela imagina o potencial que teria isso
as escolas ou melhor potencial teria
isso quando as escolas começarem ensinar
seus conteúdos com foco na escuta na
transmissão utilizam de desenho só as
empresas usarem isso dar feedback para
fazer reuniões e aí o meu convite pra
vocês
desenhei as idéias que vocês ouvirem
desenha convença que você tiver com seu
companheiro ou companheira desenha
reunião com seu chefe pode ser que ele
acha estranho mas explica antes desenho
porque eu tenho certeza que a gente
desenhando como escuta atenta a gente
vai conseguir construir um mundo muito
mais simpático um tráfego de cada vez
muito grata
[Aplausos]